– Das war der beste Abend seit langer Zeit.
– Das finde ich auch.
Erinnerst du dich noch an die
tollen Partys damals?
– Oh ja.
Unsere Nachbarn haben
einiges mitgemacht.
Zum Glück haben sie sich selten
über die laute Musik aufgeregt.
– Die Partys im Pudelclub, das
waren die tollsten.
Wir sind nie vor Sonnenaufgang
nach Hause gegangen.
– Und man ist nach einer guten Feier
auch nie alleine nach Hause gegangen.
– Du vielleicht nicht. Ich war immer brav.
– Ich vermisse die alten Zeiten.
– Ja, manches davon vermisse ich
und manches auch nicht.
– Was meinst du?
– Na ja, ich bin doch glücklich.
Wieso sollte ich also
irgendetwas anderes vermissen?
– Du kannst nur glücklich sein,
wenn du etwas vermissen kannst.
– Ja, du warst schon immer
die Klügere von uns beiden.
– Blödsinn.
Ich mag deinen Laden.
– Ich auch.
– Mach’s gut.